jantei com o Neymar nunca mais na minha
vida eu faço isso que eu não tô ficando
doido e aí eu tô lá de boa do nada uma
mensagem
Neymar quer jantar eu falei ô meu Deus
eu podia estar jantando eu terminar de
jantar para ir jantar com o Neymar meu
amigo
aí fui cheguei lá um hotel de rico
restaurante dentro do hotel de rico
dentro do restaurante só velho rico rico
rico rico rico um monte de velho rico e
umas pessoas nova esperando os velho
Morrer para pegar o dinheiro dos velhos
e eu entrei e era tanto rico que parece
que eu desaprendi a andar eu
e o povo gente um pobre olha
filma eu nunca vi um de perto gente e o
menino papai compra um desse para mim
eu falei meu irmão
[Aplausos]